e J FA ich habe zwei Fragen an dich ja
ich wollte einmal wissen ob du die mit
visaen one vorstellen könntest ich würd
es auf jeden Fall machen ich glaube du
wirürdest auch machen aber ich wollte
noch mal auf Nummer sicher gehen und ich
wollte noch fragen wie das mit Tai ist
ob ihr euch noch mal ausgeklärt habt ja
ausgesprochen habt ja das war eigentlich
so okay mit Visa ich habe eine Freundin
von on daher kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen ich bin also mehr Sex als ich
schon habe kann ich auch nicht mehr
haben mein Terminplan ist voll und von
daher Kön ich mir jetzt jetzt nicht
vorstellen wenn ich jetzt Single wä dann
warum nicht wenn sie dann auch Single
wä kann man ja mal
ausprobieren
so weiter geht ach genau taii ich habe
taii ich bin mal auf gestoßen da war so
ein Typ ich weiß nicht mehr wie er heißt
die Fron zwis uns geklärt dann habe ich
noch ein AK bei taii abgestaubt wir muss
hat uns gezwungen zusammen Foto zu
machen war so ein großer Typ aus Berlin
ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie he aber
cool drauf wie heißt den noch mal der
war echt cool scheiße wie heißt der noch
mal Afro Hesse Grüße an dich der dann so
genommen jetzt lieb und wir machen jetzt
ein Foto zu dritt und das ist jetzt auch
gut so den F ist korrekt und taii auch
ich kenne euch nämlich beide es gibt
hier auch nichts mehr ja dann muss man
ein Foto zusammen machen d die Saag dann
war war die Luft auch raus
ja